ثقب النفاث يثير الرعب في امريكا والعالم
قد يحدث صدعا بقاع المحيط الهادئ ويتحول
لزلزال مدمر بقوه تسع درجات على مقياس
ريختر
هذا الثقب يتواجد على طول خط صداع يقدر
طوله ب 600 ميل ويمتد من كاليفورنيا الى
كندا ومع ان الثقبه قديم وموجود منذ عام
2015 الى ان الكارثه تتمثل في السائل
المنبعث منه الذي يطلق عليه زيت التشحيم
المرعب في الامر ان هذا النوع من الزيوت
يسمح للصفائح التكتونيه بالتحرك بسهوله مع
قد يؤدي لوقوع الكوارث الزلزاليه ضربه
اخرى قد تضاف لسجل الزلازل المدمره التي
تضرب كوكبا فمع زياده هذا السائل الموجود
في شقوق الصدوع يقل الضغط بين الصفيحتين
التكتونيتين وبدونها يمكن ان يزداد الضغط
تحت القشره الارضيه ويسبب زلزالا مدمرا
[موسيقى]